repeating a little bit cuz i came across
a reduction show and show the problem is
easy they can apportion show that our
problems hard they can they can allow a
show that the proof techniques propagate
between different problems and and the
study of reduction raises new new kinds
of questions it also helps to identify
this is what we're going to do in this
talk identify central problems that
their solution is going to apply the
solution to many other problems as well
and it sort of will allow or hopefully
will allow to generate some kind of
taxonomy and get inspired by a
computational complexity cluster in the
space of all communication problems into
these the clusters fighing may to be
complete problems for each and every
cluster and in such as steering are we
research and so last time i mentioned a
bunch of different connections that have
been the sort of came up over the last
few years between network coding index
coding interference alignment and so on
and then in this time i want to talk
about that removal problem and show its
connections to a bunch of other problems
that seem at least is at first unrelated
so I'm going to start out with a little
bit of preliminaries just to set a
common ground and then I'll go through
the presented problem so I'm going to
talk mostly about noiseless network that
is network coding and in this setting
where we're given a graph it's a
directed network it has a bunch of sorts
where this is a bunch of terminal
vertices that are a bunch of
requirements this si wants to
communicate with this other TJ and so on
and what we want to do is of course
design some kind of flow of information
over this over this network that
satisfies the requirement so that's
that's the setting and I'm going to show
many different problems throughout the
talk so I'm going to give a little bit
of simplifying assumptions some are
needed some are not needed but I won't
specify exactly throughout the talk I'm
going to have our network be a cyclic
and we're going to have edges of the
network have a capacity CH edge is going
to have a capacity edgy will have
capacity C of E
I'm going to have the sources at this
from both of the talk I'm going to have
the sources holding independent
information and I'm also going to
consider the case in which the demand
structure between sources and terminals
is a simple one of multiple unicast in
which they're just k source terminal
pairs SI TI and SI wants to communicate
with tia that's the setting for most of
the talk and when I say SI wants to
communicate with T I'll just to find
this rigorously or semi regularly a
communication at a certain rate R 1 2 RK
each source s is communicating it rate
RI is achievable on a certain instance
with block length and if the following
happens this is very natural very
standard if we can assign random
variables SI to the sources and xe2 each
and every edge of the network such that
the following things will happen so
what's going to happen first of all you
want the sources to have high rate that
is radar I so source SI is going to be
independent and uniform with it with
support 2 to the power of Rin so that's
the rate we want these random variables
X e corresponding to edges we want them
to be a we want to be able to
communicate them over an edge we want
the support of the edge to be able to
capture the random variable so these
random variables are going to have
support which is still the power of C e
times n for an edge E so think of
sources being generated uniformly and
random variables on edges are just
random variables that can be expressed
by the capacity of the edge and of
course we want this assignment of random
variables over the network to allow some
kind of flow of information so what we
want essentially is that for every
outgoing edge of a node its random
variable as a function of the incoming
information again very standard
at the end we have our terminals they
have to do decoding so each one has an
estimate each terminal TI is going to
have an estimate of its source that it
wants and we're going to say that
communication is successful with
probability 1 over epsilon if all the
terminals can decode successfully and
the only source of random is because the
network is without any noise it's just
the randomness of the sources so if
we're able to communicate at this rate
i'm just going to use the following
terminology and i think this is the most
kind of technical slide i'm going to say
that we have radar 12 RK or radar 12 RK
is epsilon and feasible if for block
length a and an error epsilon and i'm
able to communicate this at this rate so
that's i'm going to use that quite a lot
and i'm also going to use this kind of
terminology r12 RK without the epsilon n
is feasible if it's feasible for every
epsilon so for every episode larger than
zero when epsilon x 20 there exists a
large enough n such that i'm able to
communicate and the capacity region of a
network is going to be the closure of
all these feasible couples are so again
this is very very dead
okay so I want to sort of talk about the
edge removal problem that was discussed
in the last lecture of Michelle awesome
this is a problem that was sort of
suggested a few years ago by michelle
and and co-ops so i give it a network
let's a multiple unicast and I know that
I can communicate over this network with
a certain grade topple r 1 to r k so r 1
target sativa blonde the network this
network has a certain edge e and this
edgy has a certain capacity Delta and
the question and we're asking here is
what happens to my communication
capabilities when I remove this edge e
from the network so what can be said
regarding the achievable rate on this
new on the new network and without
without the edge
another word what is a guarantee in
Larson right when I sort of removed or
when I have one link like failing inside
this network
so what is the lesson right when we're
moving a delta capacity edge and it's a
pretty easy to see that there are
examples in which if you remove a delta
capacity edge the rate is going to
decrease by Delta each other we
coordinate exactly like to show in the
previous lecture and here's an example
it's just a butterfly example in this
example you can communicate a great 1
comma 1 in the sense that if each edge
has capacity one and you can just send
these bits over over the network with a
block length one and communicated this
right and this weight is optimal but now
if you sort of maybe change this
bottleneck edge into a bunch of edges
each one of capacity Delta let's say one
over Delta of them and remove one of
them then again it's very easy to see
that the best you can do in this case is
to communicate at rate 1 minus Delta
comma 1 minus Delta so you're losing a
delta capacity in each coordinate when
you're removing a delta capacity edge
because for each and every source
terminal pair here we have s1 going to t
1 and s 2 go into t2 they need this this
bottleneck age so you lose a delta an
additive term in each coordinate in this
butterfly example and the question is
what is the price of edge removal in
general
and here's the edge removal a sort of
statement it's not known to be true it's
not known to be far so we haven't proven
it and we don't have a counterexample
for it but it states that any network
coding instances are 12 RK feasible on a
network and with a certain edgy if I
remove this edge you that has capacity
delta i get r 1 minus delta up to our
came instead
so I said it's not known to be a true or
false but it is known to be true in
several special cases so there are cases
which the removal of a delta capacity
edge is going to give you exactly or at
most it's going to give you this kind of
loss in each and every coordinate so
what are the cases the first case is the
case of the multicast communication in
which we have one source that holds all
the information all the information of
this source is going to be communicated
to all all the terminals so all the
terminals want all the information in
this case if you remove any edge of
capacity Delta then you get a delta
decreasing rate at most sort of similar
is the case of co-located sources and
co-located sources again we have one
source or with all the information but
now all the each and every terminal may
want a different subset of information
so get in this case what you get is that
removing a delta capacity edge you're
losing just Delta
and if your network has coding functions
which are linear coding functions then
in that case you can also prove that
removing a delta capacity and lots of
Delta as a question again is this true
for any any network coding in and you
can relax this problem a little bit and
not think of this very strict
requirement going from this rate up 0 r
1 to r quedo right type of r 1 minus
Delta R K minus Delta you can think of a
more a asymptotic edge removal statement
which it's a little bit dense but which
says essentially the following let's say
that I have a network and I have my my
edge my delicate pass the edge is really
dealt a capacity and since the deltas
are small very small butts in the
glitterball capacity so i can have block
length to n and i can have the edge
being of capacity log n over n in the
sense that communicates only log in bits
so if my edges has very very low
capacity vanishing capacity is it the
case that it affects my rate helpful
also in a vanishing way when I remove it
so even this asymptotic edge removal
statement which seems very very natural
if I remove a negligible capacity edge
from the network I shouldn't get that
much of a change or maybe yes or maybe
not from from the in the new network
when this it is removed so like to
understand so for the linear code case
for example you sit through this you say
other linear code it's making everybody
happy now I lose that edge I have to
make a new linear code that doesn't use
that edge that still makes everyone
happy and has way that all the all the
greats from time by Delta right so I'm
saying something a little bit different
I'm saying that if I have a linear code
on my network and I remove another
capacity edge I have another code by
chance is also linear but I the thing is
that i have another code on the network
without the edge that that's not far
away from it only only delta far away
you constructing this
this proof is it over the same field yet
and is this true for vector linear also
welcome to be sure have to think about
that I'm not sure
essentially the proof here uses a just
it uses the so it's zero is out a matrix
and it uses the zero space of a matrix
which is the linear transformation and
it could be may be extended to go also
vector then you're not completely ok so
the edge of all this statement is not
known the asymptotic a truthful
statement is not and known to be true
and the question is what what can we do
with it so it seems like a very simple
problem but but it's currently curfew so
before we sort of maybe talk about what
we do with that removal problem if we
would know that it solved let's see what
happens in noisy networks because what
we're thinking about this network coding
which was up to now noiseless networks
so if the networks are noisy edge
removal does not that's not no not to
hold our show two examples a 15 verse
area noise when from memory less noise
so think of it communicating over a
network in which has like a jamming
adversary so if you think about
point-to-point communication you can
think of a sender eggs or receiver why
this is a binary channel you're sending
n bits and then the adversary can flip
let's say your p4p n bits out of this
out of this channel so that's of course
this point to point is a very well known
model let's add a very low rate in the
glitterball rate side channel between x
and y and now in this network which has
both this channel which can be jammed
and the side channel the way you can
communicate is by sending some
information over the channel y can now
lists the code instead of unique
decoding and you can sort of send either
a hash you can just send any actually
random string over this channel is going
to help y disambiguate so over this
channel the communication rate will be
the list accordingly but of course if
you remove this link then you're back to
the standard unique decoding rate and so
there's a big gap so in this case in
adversarial noise if I remove this edge
which is negligible it's like log in
bits out of a block length of n then the
rate the rate drops dramatically
and we have a similar example in the
membranous noise a case so in this case
we're looking at the multiple access
Channel and it lets multiple access
jelly have two senders they're
independent they go through a channel
why want to decode and in this case also
we add some kind of gadget here the
gadget was very simple here you can add
a gadget we call this gadget our
cooperation facilitator in which it
takes all the information of x1 all the
information of x2 it does some kind of
computation and then in a very low rate
channel it gives back information to x 1
+ 2 x2 and once you have this negligible
channel between it gives additional
information to x1 x2 you can get a
higher rate of communication and if you
remove this channel the communication
rate drops dramatically specifically we
design a certain channel that that has
this property that for all channels this
will happen but for cereal noise and for
memoryless noise removing an edge can
have a significant effect yet so this is
clearly delta cases is also true in the
continuity case so these two examples
are actually the continuity case in the
sense that this edge is log n over n
capacity in this edge it's going to have
capacity which is any epsilon that i
want it's not vanishing but it's going
to be any constant absent that I want a
so that the trick here is that we need
the alphabet size to grow with the
capacity of the edge so there's a little
delicate see here but this is truly
asymptotically this is almost as in
tellico
okay so what's the price of its removal
it's not known not even a this relaxed
statement and the challenge in general
and improving this edge removal problem
is that we have a code for n we want to
design a quote for and without the edgy
and designing a code friend without the
edgy turns out to be pretty challenging
but and this is the whole idea of this
paradigm of reductions we don't know the
answer but we can still understand what
the implications would be if the answer
were true or if the answer was false and
what I want to show now is just a bunch
of different other problems that are
related to the edge removal problem that
I first seemed a at least to us
unrelated so I'm going to talk about
implications on reliability and it will
communication on topology of networks on
the demand structure and on corporation
in general in networks I'm going to show
these disconnects
okay let's start with the outlet
reliability now present another question
which is the zero vs epsilon error
communication question so again our
starting point is a graph a multiple
sources multiple terminals we have this
multiple unicast communication
requirement and let's say that we can
communicate a radar one up to RK on this
network but we can communicate only when
we have a probability of epsilon it
could maybe 10 20 but we have always
some probability of epsilon that our
communication is going to fail and this
question that we're raising we're asking
okay what happens a what I want to
insist on zero error in communication so
I know that our want our cake can be
achievable when I have a little bit of
error what can I say when I want to
insist on I'm 0f so again what is the
cost in rate that I have to pay when I
want to make sure that i'm communicating
at zero or not excellent yeah so in
general if one asks ok can I obtain a
higher rate of communication when I'm
allowing epsilon error or not as opposed
to zero or the answer in general and
general networks are noisy networks a in
particular that the answer is going to
be yes absolutely error helps if there's
some air you can get a higher a higher
rate one example even in the case in
which there is no noise but the sources
are dependent is a certain Wolffe
problem the sources are dependent if I
want to succeed for most cases I can do
it with very high rate if I want to
succeed for all cases that is with no
probability of error then the rate
significantly reduces
average of the several messages or
resources or is it maximum double D so
the only so what we're doing here is our
networks are noises so the only source
of randomness is the sources the source
message so it would because if you have
exactly so if the network has noise and
it's not uh no is this network then of
course you're going to benefit from
epsilon error as opposed to zero so
we're asking okay we're assuming
independent sources and noiseless
network and we're asking what happens in
this case what about the network coding
scenario when there's no noise and all
the sources are independent again is
there an advantage in epsilon vs 0 0
case up to now we had two problems the
edge removal problem yes five minutes
left okay so I'm not gonna finish the
talk but I'll do it a little bit faster
okay we have a surprise so any how many
would they believe that they'd removal
statement is true oh I'm asking yeah
just ask yes I don't have time anyway so
I'm gonna ask cloud and what about the
episode vs 0 error is it ok so the
stable would be something like this
would be that if I'm are 12 RK feasible
with error epsilon then I'm going to
lose a little bit if I insist on 0 error
but this little bit delta is gonna
depend on you
I will no photo so my intuition at least
was an edge removal true zero error
false but it turns out and I'll just
jump ahead because I'm a little bit
short in time that they are the same so
it turns out for example that edge
removal is true if and only if the zero
error the Niger is known but neither is
no yeah so that removal statement is
true if and only if this zero error
statement which I went through very
quickly the zero error statement so you
want to repeat it so again it says
something of the sort that if I'm are 12
RK feasible with error epsilon and
epsilon this content 20 then I'm losing
a little bit in rate I'm going to be r 1
minus Delta R K minus Delta feasible
with the 0 in the network coding Richie
and the way we prove these kind of
results again we don't know if the edge
removers true or not yeah so both
direction so the flow of the talk
already I wanted to say that this is
this has two directions of course and
for example proving one direction it
will have the following kind of flavor
to it we're assuming that we can
communicate with epsilon error we're
also assuming that edge removal is true
and will show that you can communicate
at zero error with a little bit less so
that will be one direction the other
direction well is it similar so this is
an if and only if a statement okay so I
have to replan so how much more time do
I have I'm gonna jump very program is
known as lunch so you know you can cut
the lunch but you may get in trouble no
but for known how much time you're known
is like three minutes okay okay good
okay so what I'll do is lay so I'll do
okay I'll do one more problem then I'll
jump to Dan okay right now yeah you're
very nice care okay I do pecado the
three minutes three minutes okay so I
want to talk about topology of it works
also so as Michelle mentioned recent
studies have shown that there's
connections between network coding and
index coding instances in the sense we
can take any natural coding instance
turn it into an index coding instance in
such a way that if you we solve the
index coding its if we can get a
solution to the network coding instance
this is recent work and it's a it's a
very nice reduction or I think it's a
nice reduction in the sense that somehow
it it allows to separate the difficulty
or two difficulties in there for
communication one is that the fact that
we're looking at a topology and the
other one is we have to encode so if you
have to encode information also when
you're insisting of preserving these
topological constraints it becomes more
difficult and here if reducing
everything to index coding it's very
simpler because there's only one know
that does encoding okay so there was an
issue in in this reduction is that it
takes it says that any network coding
instance is our feasible if it only if
its corresponding index coding instance
is some our privacy bowl for some
function of our in general what it does
it takes any code in the index coding
regime it's going to turn it into a code
then if recording regime and pretty
surprisingly this does not extend to a
reduction which answers the following
very related question which is can one
determine the capacity region of I'm
sorry a network code using the capacity
region of an index code so it's a kind
of subtle I can design any code for it
recording by studying a similar code for
index coding but doesn't that mean that
I can actually characterize a capaz
region of a network coding using the
capacity region of an index coding and
the answer is no the problem is that all
that this reduction breaks down when you
look at the closure operation so there's
still an issue of closure and again a
one could ask a how to overcome byzant
and this was open and it's been a
difficult and challenging problem but
I'll just say in one word that edge
removal resolves is also and just like
the previous case we get an if and only
if connection the sense that we can
characterize the capacitive net
recording with the capacitive index
coding if and only if this asymptotic
its removal statement is actually jump
almost to the end
and you didn't see this but the this
edge removal statement turns out to be
not only connected to the zero vs
epsilon error condition not only to the
fact that we can connect between
reduction in capacity in reduction in
code design for index coding it also is
connected to the difference between
communicating over a network with
dependent sources and communicating over
network with independent sources and
it's also connected to the fact that you
can communicate or take any network with
many different communication demands
Assize tjs i want SI and turn them into
a very simplistic network there's a
beautiful recent work that is just a two
unicast network so add removal sort of
connects all these problems together or
open issues in all of these problems and
again just maybe one other way to view
this is that this edge removal captures
the notion of slackness and it shows
that different types of slackness are
are equivalent so what do I mean if you
think of removing a delta capacity edge
and wanting the way to reduce by Delta
it means that if you're a slight have a
slight slackness in edge capacity it
doesn't really matter the zero vs
epsilon error statement says that if you
have a slide slackness in reliability
again it doesn't really matter this
notion of capacity reduction versus code
reduction says that if you have a slight
slackness in this notion of closer it
also really doesn't matter so it could
be and this is sort of work in progress
and we want to define this rigorously
but it could be that all these forms of
slackness are are actually equivalent
and and in this case this these problems
of this statement a came to life by
studying this edge removal
so just a few minutes later okay thank
you
so I have one that I have been taking a
bit so for example none of these
reductions explicitly discusses leash
approximation right so let's say I had a
handful unicast algorithm that was
within let's say a low key factor from
which by the way I believe is possible
to do for summary so in for the summer
in for multiple unicast approximating
within let's say locally popular case
and under accession how would now in
this reduction for example dimension we
can reduce the two unicast how would my
approximation factor you know change so
it's a good this was never discussed and
i think is a very important point so we
do have a work which proves that you
could not approximate the multiple
unicast communication problem within a
certain factor alpha if you do then this
sort of gives you is some type of a
coloring of a graph for i think some
rate will follow from this because the
i'm pretty sure the subtitle file from
this but this I have to check a
rigorously but this does not rule out
the log maybe log N and not lock a but a
login approximation it doesn't rule out
a login approximation and your your
question was how do these the least
preserve approximation or not and
actually I didn't think about that so
that would be nice to discuss that blend
up
so it's you have to open all this
pollution see very careful another
questions so you need the edge room that
was funny because we're trying to prove
there's removal conjecture and in
parallel I was trying to find a counter
example for the episode versus we're
sort of pushing bond both of these
pretty hard so actually I'm not I'm not
completely sure
right let's think